I was hoping I'd find you here
Phil
last time we spoke he didn't seem to
have much to say to me yeah
I wasn't ready to go there yet but uh
I'm here now
okay
well
I'm listening
you know when he told Will about his
father
I don't think I'd ever been angry
I knew you'd be living when you found a
home
right
see that's the thing gee
he better than anyone
you knew how I'd reacted
did it anyway
which means you had a damn good reason
I know you've been thinking about
Frederick
how are you doing
I'm feeling great about
the decisions I've made Phil
he's my son
but you know why you can't see him yeah
I know I get it for this very reason
because if your emotions can I get it
through I understand [__] Arrangement
I'm not an idiot you know I'm the one
that made it here I get it
but here
he's my family you understand I am too
no no no no no no you made it perfectly
clear I work for you
that's why I am truly sorry for what I
said
I was disrespectful
I was out of line and
I will never
let that happen again
it's gonna take time you know I
understand that
but just know that I love you bro
you all do
come back home and let us show you how
much
[Music]